nos pide que resolvamos el valor
absoluto de 3x menos 9 esto es igual a
cero y que grafique mos la solución en
una recta numérica y lo primero que
quiero hacer es copiar de nuevo la
ecuación con valor absoluto y me queda
que el valor absoluto de 3x menos 9 esto
es igual a cero y bueno date cuenta que
la única solución de esta ecuación como
lo absoluto es que 3x menos 9 es igual a
cero si yo tengo que el valor absoluto
de algo es igual a cero ese algo tiene
que ser forzosamente cero recuerda que
el valor absoluto lo podríamos ver como
la distancia que había el cero y si yo
tengo que la distancia que hay del cero
es igual a cero pues no me moví es decir
que me quedan el cero o dicho de otra
manera lo podemos pensar también como
esto si yo me tomo el valor absoluto de
algún número y esto es igual a cero no
queda de otra este número tiene que ser
igual a cero porque imagínate si yo
tuviera valor absoluto de algo igual a
uno pues hay dos sopas o que esté algo
sea igual a uno o que sea igual a menos
uno pero aquí en este caso tendríamos
que este algo o es cero o es igual a
menos cero pero ser menos cero es lo
mismo por lo tanto no queda de otra 3x
menos 9 es igual a cero así que date
cuenta que el paso más importante
ejercicio ya lo hicimos que es darnos
cuenta que lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto tendrá que ser igual a cero y
como lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto es igual a cero entonces 13 x
menos 9 es lo que tiene que ser igual a
cero espero que hasta aquí vayamos en
orden y bueno para resolver esta
ecuación lo que hay que hacer es primero
sumar 9 de ambos lados de la ecuación
así que voy a sumar 9 y voy a sumar 9 y
que me quedan 3 x menos 9 más 9 pues
menos 99 se van y me queda simple y
sencillamente 3x esto de lado izquierdo
mientras que el lado derecho me queda 0
más 90 más 99 y bueno si yo quiero
despejar a x lo único que hay que hacer
es pasar este 3 del otro lado con su
operación contraria o dicho de otra
manera lo que voy a hacer es dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 3 para
que así se pueda cancelar este 3 me
queda 3 x entre 3 pues esto es 1 x que
es lo mismo que x y del otro lado me
quedan 9 entre 3 lo cual es 3 es decir
que x igual a 3 es la solución de esta
ecuación con valor absoluto de la
ecuación el valor absoluto de 3 x 99 es
igual a 0 que de hecho sería bastante
bueno que lo corroboramos como en el
vídeo pasado ya hicimos la gráfica vamos
a hacer
comprobación de que en efecto nos de 0
así que vamos a ver el valor absoluto de
3 por 3 porque recuerda que x es igual a
entonces nos quedaría el valor absoluto
de 3 x 3 menos 9 esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 pero 3 x 3 es 99 menos 9 en
valor absoluto tiene que ser igual a 0
pero 9 menos 90 y el valor absoluto de
cero es cero
por lo tanto x igual a 3 es la solución
de esta ecuación con valor absoluto